se puede pensar en la función g como una
versión escala de fx igual a x al
cuadrado escribe la ecuación para ge x
como siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por ustedes mismos muy
bien hagámoslo juntos lo primero que
tenemos que observar es que la función g
no sólo parece que se reflejó sobre el
eje x sino que se reflejó y se estiró a
lo ancho así que hagamos esto paso a
paso primero vamos a reflejar respecto
al eje x reflejamos respecto al eje x de
modo que si lo queremos hacer
visualmente esto quedaría así cuando x
es igual a 0 que seguirá siendo igual a
0 pero cuando x es igual a menos 1 en
lugar de que ya sea igual a 1 ahora será
igual a menos uno cuando x es igual a 1
en lugar de elevar 1 al cuadrado y
obtener 1 tomamos el negativo de eso
para obtener menos 1 así que cuando lo
reflejamos se ve así cuando x es igual a
menos 2 y en lugar de ser igual a 4 será
igual a menos 4 entonces se verá así
así que mientras hablamos estamos
tratando de dibujar esta versión
reflejada cualquiera que sea el valor de
ya que estábamos obteniendo antes para
una x dada ahora obtenemos lo opuesto o
lo negativo por lo que la función que
tenemos aquí en verde va a ser igual a
menos f x o podríamos decir que es igual
a menos x cuadrada para cualquier valor
de x lo elevada al cuadrado y luego
tomas el valor negativo de eso y puedes
ver que eso refleja la función respecto
al eje x pero eso por sí solo no nos
permite obtener gx gx también parece que
está estirada en la dirección horizontal
así que pensemos si podemos multiplicar
esto por un factor de escala de modo que
se haga este estiramiento y podamos
emparejar la con ge x la mejor manera de
hacerlo es elegir un punto que
pertenezca a gdx y de hecho nos dan 1
aquí nos dan el punto 2 coma menos 1 que
se encuentra en g x cuando x es igual a
2 que es igual a menos uno en x así que
podemos decir que de 2 es igual a menos
ahora en nuestra función verde cuando x
es igual a 2 que es igual a menos 4 así
que veamos probablemente podemos
multiplicar esto por un cuarto para
obtener nuestra g vamos a ver si
escalamos a un cuarto esto nos dará la
respuesta escalar a un cuarto
en ese caso vamos a tener que es igual a
no solo menos x al cuadrado sino que va
a ser igual a menos un cuarto de x al
cuadrado y si te preguntas como
obtuvimos un cuarto bueno me fijé en x
igualados en nuestra función verde
cuando x es igual a 2 obtuve menos 4
queremos que cuando becky sea igual a 2
el resultado sea menos uno menos uno es
un cuarto de menos cuatro por eso es que
pensé multiplicar nuestra función verde
por un cuarto esto parece que la puede
emparejar con gx y vamos a verificarlo
cuando x es igual a cero bueno esto
sigue siendo cero y tiene sentido cuando
x es igual a 1 entonces 1 al cuadrado
por menos un cuarto bueno eso sin duda
va a ser igual a menos un cuarto justo
aquí cuando x es igual a 2 2 al cuadrado
es 4 x menos un cuarto eso sin duda es
igual a menos 1 vamos a tratar con este
punto que parece que también está en
nuestra gráfica cuando x es igual a 44
al cuadrado es 16 16 x menos un cuarto
es
4 y funciona también para los valores
negativos de x puedo decir con certeza
que esta es la ecuación de eje x gx es
igual a menos un cuarto de x al cuadrado
así que en general cuando decimos que
estamos escalando con valores negativos
esto hace que la curva se refleje
respecto al eje x y luego multiplicar la
por esta fracción que tiene un valor
absoluto menor que 1 en realidad va a
ser que se estire a lo ancho si este
valor que tenemos aquí tiene un valor
absoluto mayor que 1 entonces la
estiraría en la dirección vertical o la
haría más delgada respecto a la
horizontal hasta el próximo vídeo